let's go next to
sam
from new york city sam from new york
city you are next up what is on your
mind today my friend
sam from new york city you're on the air
hey can you hear me
now i can
awesome how are you doing i i just
wanted to call uh and ask
um another question about
afghanistan i know you've spoken a lot
about it the past few days on the show
yes i'm just wondering
a year from now
what would a successful mission look
like to you
you you're saying if we had delayed this
for a year or just what do i think
sorry i'm saying
a lot some stuff has gone right a lot's
gone wrong the past few weeks
if we look ahead to you know the summer
of 2022
given what we've already done
what ideally do you think afghanistan
would look like you know a year from now
if u.s foreign policy is successful
i think that the framing is completely
wrong i think u.s foreign policy has
failed we've been there for 20 years
we did not create
if we believe it was our goal to create
a sustainable
self-governance infrastructure in
afghanistan we failed to do it so u.s
foreign policy has failed the hope for
afghanistan would be
we get out
we deal with evacuating people our
people refugees we figure out how to
empathetically take care of people that
are in a worse situation because we've
been there for 20 years
and then in an ideal world
afghanistan
goes in the opposite direction of being
a failed state it goes in the direction
of being a working state and it there is
peace and there is sensible
self-governance but the idea that we
failed it would be happening despite
american intervention not as a result of
it and i i just disagree with the
framing
of that because we our our participation
has been a disaster
okay sam from new york city apparently
flummoxed by my response and so we're
going to move on